what an m4 Isaac  harden good for three  quickly and they both set that big  screen for him hearted step back for  three get out of his hands but he was  able to stay with it and put it back in  Westbrook  [Music]  good again backs in against bullets walk  3 by pardon got it again this three  pointed tips wide open 20 first half  points  harden is dialed in Houston has made 12  to 23 harden jacks up another one back  sit down James Harden Aaron Gordon now  on James Hart we put that might handily  part it buries another three  [Applause]  steal by Harden he'll fire for three he  got it just when it looked like you had  some momentum tenth rebound for PJ  Tucker 3-ball by Harden give him back by  the way his career-high  arnon steals it from 48 he'll pull back  and fire for three he has matched his  career-high with ten threes in the